Estás pensando en el dinero y tus metas,
y miras la cuenta bancaria.
Y te das cuenta de que no se ajusta a tus sueños.
[Nuestra forma de trabajar]
La economía doméstica puede ser un desafío para cualquier familia.
El 46 % de los estadounidenses tiene dificultades
para reunir 400 dólares en caso de emergencia.
Y un 60 % de estadounidenses pasará por esa experiencia
en de los próximos 12 meses.
Ante la pregunta: "¿Qué significa para ti el dinero?",
la mayoría dirá algo como: "Me pongo de los nervios".
Y ahí vienen las inseguridades. La vergüenza.
La relación que tenemos con el dinero es muy delicada
porque está llena de opiniones.
Si no puedes pagar las facturas a tiempo
te afecta de forma personal.
No quieres que nadie piense que eres un incapaz.
No quieres que piensen que tienes inseguridades con el dinero.
No quieres que sepan que estás muy agobiado.
Así que cambiemos la forma de verlo.
[6 lecciones para mejorar tu relación con el dinero]
[1. Habla sobre el tema]
No puedes hacerlo tú solo. Necesitas un grupo de confianza.
Es un tabú.
No solemos hablar del estrés que nos genera el dinero.
Tenemos que apoyarnos como un grupo de amigos.
Sin juicios, sin vergüenza.
Y ensalzar el hecho de que hemos tomado la decisión
de mejorar nuestra forma de ver el dinero,
y de que esto es algo que hay que celebrar.
Luego es hora de afrontar la realidad.
No hay temas prohibidos.
¿De dónde viene esta relación con el dinero?
¿Por qué gasto todo este dinero en cosas que no se ajustan a mis metas?
¿Tienes miedos, ilusiones, metas?
Después se pasa a la acción.
¿Qué mejoramos esta semana, este mes?
[2. Entiende qué es el dinero]
El dinero no es lo más importante.
Es el mecanismo para alcanzar tus metas.
No te define.
Sirve para lograr lo que te importa.
[3. Identifica lo que te importa...]
Pregúntate: ¿para qué estás ahorrando?
Si ahorras para comprar un coche, para pagar tus deudas,
para un fondo de emergencia,
tienes que considerar metas a corto plazo
y metas a largo plazo.
[4. ...y visualízalo.]
Imagina con todas tus fuerzas tus metas.
Un mapa de sueños es una representación visual
de aquello para lo que ahorras.
Paso a paso: toma una cartulina.
Toma rotuladores, purpurina...
recortes de revistas...
Una foto de aquel viaje tan especial.
Un recuerdo de cuando pagaste la matrícula de la universidad.
Igual estás pensando: "¿De verdad me va a ayudar?"
Tus metas tienen que estar en línea con tu comportamiento,
y el mapa de sueños es una representación
de a dónde quieres llegar y de cómo tienes que vivir,
y los pasos que tienes que dar para llegar hasta ahí.
[5. No es lo que ganas, es lo que ahorras.]
No se trata de cuánto ganas, sino de cuánto ahorras.
Se trata de comprender si tienes la capacidad
de cubrir tus necesidades básicas con el dinero que tienes.
Y en caso de no ser así, ¿qué tengo que cambiar?
Y, paso a paso, aprendemos cómo se hace.
¿Tienes una cuenta de ahorro y transferencias automáticas?
Lo haces una vez y te olvidas, o quizás ahorras un dólar al día.
Al ritmo que mejor funcione en tu caso,
lo que importa es hacerlo, no la cantidad.
Ve poco a poco.
No tienes que empezar a lo grande, pero tienes que empezar ya.
Y un consejo, todos tenemos impulsos.
Muchas veces, como tenemos siempre el móvil cerca,
empezamos a comprar.
Ve a una página, si te gusta algo, ponlo en el carro
pero no lo compres todavía.
Espera 24 hs. y pregúntate:
"¿De veras lo necesito?"
"¿Puedo relacionar este artículo con mis metas?"
Y si la respuesta es no, elimínalo, no lo compres.
[6. Sé comprensivo contigo mismo.]
Es importante tener en cuenta
que tu autoestima no se determina por tus ingresos.
Esto es algo que se puede mejorar.
Celebra tus logros.
Y cuando te equivoques, no te juzgues, no te avergüences.
Simplemente vuelve a empezar.